This three-step ICT strategy got me
payouts like this, this, and this. And
I'm about to show you exactly how. I've
been trading for 14 years and have
tested hundreds of complicated ICT
strategies, and this is one of the only
ICT strategies that works every day.
Today, I'm going to teach you the full
strategy, show you live trade examples,
that way you have everything you need to
finally become a successful trader. So,
first we need to lay out the foundation
of our trade and mark the key levels
where we're going to look for
opportunities. So, to do this, we break
this down into two key parts. First is
going to be marking out the previous
daily highs and lows. So, when we are
talking about our daily highs and lows,
let's just say we have this specific
block of price action. And this
represents 24 hours of our trading day.
Now, I'm talking about midnight Eastern
to midnight Eastern. Okay, so inside of
this, we might have price action, right,
intraday that's creating what? A
previous daily high and then our
previous daily low. So, we want to be
able to understand what inside of this
24-hour window, what is the highest
price and what is the lowest price.
Okay, this gives us an idea of if we're
trying to get long, maybe we're going to
target the previous day's high, right,
on that following day. Or maybe if we're
short, we're trying to trying to target
the previous day's low. Okay, very
straightforward. Now, when it comes to
areas of premium and discount, we're
going to mark out what? Fair value gaps,
order blocks, and maybe Fibonacci
retracements. Okay, don't try and add
too many things in here. You just want
to try and keep things as simple as
possible. Based off of these concepts,
we have three different entry models,
and to be honest, you don't even need
these two. You can get away with using
only fair value gaps when you're
trading. What I'm going to actually do
is inside of this intraday price action,
we're going to mark out any fair value
gap. So, we might have a bullish fair
value gap that was broken up here, which
created an inverted fair value gap. And
then maybe in here, we have a bearish
fair value gap in here. Okay, we're
going to mark both of these out along
with our previous day's high here. So,
we have our previous day's high and then
our previous day's low. Okay, after
marking out this price action, let's
just say going into the following day,
we have this divider here, which marks
out our midnight. So, after we've
identified our key levels, again, this
should only take you a couple minutes at
the end of every day. So, typically
during like Asian session or maybe even
right before the market opens the
following day, I'm sitting down in front
of my charts and I'm very quickly just
marking out previous day's highs,
previous day's lows, and then any
important levels that I'm trying to find
intraday. So, maybe there's a bullish
fair value gap, maybe there's a bearish
fair value gap. I just mark that out
intraday so I know what I'm looking at
for that following day. All right, now
we've got all our levels marked, which
is great. However, knowing where we want
to take trades is totally useless if you
don't know when we want to trade. So,
when we're mapping out our trade, we
have to do a couple things. We have to
understand the calendar, and this is
going to allow us to time our trade
properly. Also, how to avoid poor
setups. So, I'll get into that bit in
just a minute. But, when we're studying
a calendar, let's just say I'm bearish
on this specific day because we've
broken market structure down here. So,
when I look at this intraday market,
yes, it's very sideways, but we get a
strong displacement towards the end of
the day. What I'm anticipating the
following day, however, let's say this
market closed bearish on the day, I'm
looking for continued bearish price
action the following day. Now, based on
the calendar, uh maybe we have a
high-impact news event around the open,
or maybe we don't have any news at all.
In both cases, though, what I'm
anticipating though is for the following
day for the market to trade higher into
some level of premium. Maybe it's going
to trade into this bearish fair value
gap, or maybe it's going to trade into
this inverted fair value gap all the way
up here. But, what needs to happen is
this market up here needs to align with
the time that I'm trying to trade. So,
let's say, for example, we have a
high-impact news event in New York, but
this is London session. Okay, am I
inclined to take this short just because
it's inside of a bearish fair value gap?
Or should I be waiting for the news
event? Maybe they're going to manipulate
the market higher. Okay, this is really
where I want to take the trade and
[music] not in here. So, I'm going to
walk you guys through a very clear
example of steps one and two. So, here
we have a chart of Nasdaq, and this is
really just an hourly chart. A lot of my
analysis is coming from the daily, the
4-hour, the 1-hour. Because I'm trading
off of these higher time frame levels,
I'm only using the low time frame to
time my entries. All right, but all of
my analysis and what I'm looking for in
the charts is really derived from these
higher time frames. So, what I'm
anticipating, okay, so let's say Friday
was bearish and maybe Monday we have a
news event, or I'm just waiting for the
market open. What am I going to
anticipate leading up into that open?
So, what I'm anticipating is this market
to slowly trade higher, okay, into this
fair value gap right at the open, okay,
hopefully not taking out the previous
day's high cuz that would kind of shift
market structure. And then I can
possibly position myself short to target
what? Previous day's lows. Okay, so this
is what I'm anticipating the following
day, and this is how I'm mapping out my
trade. So, you guys can see here that I
have this fair value gap plotted, but I
also have this inverted fair value gap
plotted. So, I have both of these
intraday levels marked out, and this is
really just so I can identify some of
the levels where we might trade to or
where we're going to have some issues
getting through. So, let's play this
market forward, and again, when I'm
trying to map out my trade, I'm trying
to get short at a premium and maybe near
the previous day's high. But, the time
has to align, so I am waiting for the
equity open. So, let's play this market
forward and just anticipate what's going
to happen next. So, we are now inside of
this inverted fair value gap. Again,
it's not at a level that I'm trying to
short, okay? What I'm looking for is the
market to trade higher here as a
manipulation ahead of the open. Now, you
can see that from a timing perspective,
if I'm trying to be bearish on the
market, this just doesn't make any
sense. All right, if I'm trying to be
bearish, I don't want to see London
pushing lower. I actually want to see it
manipulating higher so I can position
myself properly. Okay, now this is
exactly where I'm interested in the
market. Okay, it's traded up into this
fair value gap and it's given us a
bearish engulfing candle. All right, so
if I mapped out a bearish trade, again,
I'm not going to trade short into this
inverted fair value gap. That just
doesn't make any sense. I'm waiting for
a premium level that we get very, very
close to our previous day's high. So,
shorting it up here probably would have
been the best idea, but I'm actually
waiting for the close here to kind of
give me an indication that the market
wants to turn roll over. So, right at
10:00 a.m. is when I'm anticipating the
market to go short. So, let's say if I
place a short position here and then I'm
just targeting the previous day's low.
And then we run this forward, so I'm
planning out a roughly 2.4 to one
risk-to-reward. All right, this market's
coming back, it's going back to break
even. It's moving a little bit slow.
Now, we have the market roll over. This
is actually in the Asian session, and
there we go. So, this trade idea, right,
we mapped it out, we were bearish on the
day, we avoided taking the short in
here, and we waited until this market
got into a premium with a strong
rejection. Now, yes, this takes some
time for the market to actually trade in
your favor, and if you're trading a
futures prop firm, you would have had to
close on the roll over, so you might
have been up a tiny amount, but you can
close that trade ahead of the close and
just reopen it at 6:00 p.m. And as long
as the market doesn't gap too heavily,
you've essentially been in the same
trade throughout the roll over period
without breaking any of the rules. So,
this was a very straightforward trade.
Again, identifying our key levels, which
should only take us a couple minutes to
do. We had this bearish fair value gap,
and we have this inverted fair value gap
here, and we have our previous day's
high and previous day's low. I'm really
only interested if it trades to this
level here. Our entry model is here with
an engulfing candle. Basically, I just
entered short on the open of the new
candle, and then from there, it's just
all a matter of patience. Now, this
strategy's perfect for prop firms. If
you're looking for a discount, I'll
leave a link down in the description.
So, as I just showed you guys, it's very
important to identify our key levels,
our areas of premium and discount, where
we're trying to get short or long, and
then mapping out the trade, knowing when
to actually position yourself. And when
it comes to avoiding poor setups, let's
just say you're bearish the next day,
but the market really just drops lower.
So, for example, if I wanted to be
bearish on this day, but the market just
drops lower without me, essentially, I
don't have a trade. So, going forward,
let's say if we marked out this all of
these levels in here, and we had what?
This fair value gap here, okay, we have
this fair value gap all the way up here,
and these are the intraday levels that
I'm expecting the market to trade higher
to in order for me to get short. But,
instead, the market just drops without
me. Well, what do I do? I don't take any
trades. What I'm looking for is that run
higher into those previous intraday
levels before I get short. But, if the
market expands lower without me, I'm
essentially just trying to chase markets
and FOMO into them. So, really, I need
to be patient waiting for this market to
trade higher into my levels, and if it
doesn't do that, guess what? I don't
take any trades. Now, step three is the
simplest part of the entire strategy,
yet this is where most traders
everything up and stay unprofitable.
But, after you see this simple approach,
you'll never second-guess yourself
again. So, this is really just going to
be an analogy, which I've shared before,
but executing your trades as a
professional consistent trader is
probably the hardest part about trading.
Most people have a plan and they just
don't execute their trading plan. They
say that they want to be short the next
day, they find themselves in a long.
They say that they're going to risk 1%
and find themselves risking 3%. And when
it comes to executing your trading plan,
a lot of it comes down to your emotional
control. So, if I go back to this
specific trade idea, okay, if we went
short here, think about how much mental
turmoil I have to sit in before it
actually starts moving in my favor.
Okay, this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 hours of
this market just trading around on me
sideways and me battling the emotions
that come up when I'm trying to manage
the position. I see it go in profit a
little bit, I see it come against me.
All right, this is all about executing
your trading plan. If I said I wanted to
be short, just because the market goes
sideways on me does not mean I just
abandon the idea because let's say if I
abandon the idea and then all of a
sudden the market just starts moving in
my direction. That was me not following
the plan. And when it comes down to your
execution, basically, it's just about
doing what you say you're going to do.
If you say you're going to be bearish
the next day, do not go long if you're
anticipating the market to go lower just
because of what you saw on the lower
time frame. All right, the biggest
problem with execution is that traders
are just not confident enough in their
analysis and their thought processes and
their trading processes to be able to
withstand the market fluctuations in
order for them to take advantage of
specific market moves when they go to
their target. So, let's just assume, for
example, you have a target of 25k. And
let's just say that this is in
California, and then where we currently
are is New York. And we want to buy a
bus ticket to California. What happens
is you're going to get on the bus in New
York, and your destination is
California. So, let's just say that the
market starts its journey towards
California. But what happens is the bus
driver gets really tired, and he said he
needs to take a stop in Ohio. So, what
happens is maybe you're trailing your
stop. All right, the bus driver takes a
stop, a pit stop in Ohio, and stops you
out. And he says, "All right, everybody
get off the bus. I am going to take a
nap for 4 to 8 hours, and get back on
the bus, and then we're going to make
our way to California." Now, this is
where a lot of traders decide to not
execute the plan. Okay, the plan was to
get on the bus and go to California. But
there was an unforeseen circumstance.
So, here we have two decisions to make.
Do we get back on a bus because we don't
trust that it's going to get to
California, and make our way back to New
York? That's essentially you going
against your bias, and going long in the
market because you don't trust that it's
going to get to 25k. Whereas the person
that is going to execute the plan when
they got on the bus, okay, the person
that got on the bus in New York is
trying to execute a plan to get to
California. Do I get short on the market
again? Okay, so maybe there's another
setup that shows up, and they get short
on the market again. Meanwhile, the
person that's not confident in their
analysis and the strategy, they get on a
different bus and try and go in the
opposite direction back to New York
because they don't trust the bus driver.
They don't trust that this bus driver is
going to get them to California. What
happens is the market eventually gets to
California. Meanwhile, the person that
wasn't confident is all the way back in
New York, right? Now, you're stuck in
New York. Your bus that you were
supposed to get on and stay on is all
the way in California. And this is
trading in a nutshell. You have to come
into the markets with a plan and execute
that plan. Yes, the market's going to
make pit stops along the way. You can't
control what the bus driver's going to
do. This market, aka the bus driver, can
take as many pit stops as it wants. But
just because you got stopped out on one
idea does not make this trade idea
wrong. Eventually, if it gets to 25k
target, you just have to anticipate that
this bus might go on different routes to
get there. Which, if it takes different
routes, you are just not in control of
it. So, when it comes to executing your
trading plan, you have to be comfortable
with the uncertainties of the market.
You can come in here and do all of this,
identify your key levels, map out the
trade. But the biggest problem that most
traders face is when it comes time to
execute their trading plan, they
stumble. You can do some parts of this
right, but on the way to the
destination, you're making irrational
decisions that are not aligned with your
trading plan. And the biggest thing when
it comes to executing your trading plan
is you do exactly as you say. You now
have a simple and proven strategy. But
chances are you've had good strategies
before, but still aren't profitable. I
know this because I struggled for 10
years before I became profitable, which
is why I created my mentorship. This is
not your average trading Discord. It's
direct access to me, a verified
seven-figure trader, to teach you
everything I've learned in the last 14
years. I'll leave a link to apply down
in the description, but I want to be
clear. I don't work with just anyone. If
the link still works, there are slots
left. Otherwise, you can join the
waitlist. Thanks for watching. Make sure
to subscribe, and I'll see you guys in
the next video.